d'accord bien comme c'est la première
fois qu'on se voie je vous faire une
interview première fois voilà stress en
jour alors fabrice votre premier
souvenir
mon premier souvenir pour les souvenirs
de votre vie voilà moi je les ai compris
l'âge de répondre
c'est mon premier jour d'école justement
avait gardé longtemps tous les jours
d'école avait été terrible ah oui voilà
vous avez quitté votre maman c'est ça le
petit garçon s'est finalement bah oui
moi aussi j'ai un fils côté scolaire à
l'école de premières balles
vous avez reçu un jour le maire un
joueur devant un coup de poing qu'il
avait donnée donner enfin si je pense
que tout le monde à l'école mais bon en
prison j'ai commencé la boxe
maintenant c'était vrai à 12 ans est
d'accord donc la seule à vraiment
j'avais le droit votre premier péché on
y pêcher les premiers j'en suis plus
trop noble et la lenteur temps comme
tout le monde
enfin avec les filles de 14 ans non mais
bombay et qu'une poule ses péchés ou pas
les poules et lapins savoir le premier à
idole provenir idole robin pense que
quand j'ai commencé la boxe moi je veux
bien un boxeur que j'aimais bien que je
crois si vous le connaissez mais j'étais
de marvin hagler la ringer voilà donc
c'est un boxeur dur donc voila comme
étant avait d'ailleurs quand même super
si on s'intéresse un peu à la boxe on
connaît ma rigueur tuerie oui je sais
vous vous garez dit je voudrais être
aussi célèbre qu'alphonse lahlimi qu'on
parle de moi comme d'un alphonse halimi
non je voulais jeune homme passionné ça
ira en bottes on a un problème toujours
en me bitton en 2000 et en parle
toujours des anciens boxeurs et ça c'est
bon ils ont fait quelque chose qu'il
aime bien tout ça mais maintenant je
dire faut qu'ils faut qu'on arrête de
parler autant 2020 et donc c'est ce que
je dis maintenant c'est oublié je veux
laisser une trace dans la boxe comme
cerdon ou allez me fais et c'est vrai
vous avez raison c'est vrai qu'il ya 30
40 50 ans les boxeurs cerdan c'est une
énorme star quoi et c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui vous double champion du
monde est reconnue bien sûr votre nom
est connu mais vous avez aussi tard que
ça ouais ouais voilà donc
avec une catégorie aussi il est beaucoup
moins deux catégories disons que c'est
un look third avant les boxeurs d'avant
ne pourrait pas gagner maintenant je
fais des comparaisons qui sont qui sont
pas possibles
et la méditation premier amour je me
rabats mourra bas 14 ans j'ai rencontré
ma femme je vous demande pas votre
première expérience sexuelle c'est
complètement complètement amène ses
tromperies entre-temps généraux de l
arrivée de l'autre c'est possible c'est
possible qu'ils aient donc à ce pitch un
don du ciel
eh bien ça non mais une femme dans une
vie ça va c'est extraordinaire
tu vois là le ruellois
je pense à paris à mes parents mais
j'avais 18 ans bonne première cuite s'en
souvenait oui à 11 ans j'ai fait exprès
pour dire voilà mon jour des produits et
vous en avez pris d'autres après quand
même quelques quelques 1er juin causant
saison mais ça ne servira pas à brancher
et j'ai réussi pourquoi mais c'est pas
leur truc est votre premier dopage a le
droit de ne pas aimer boxer moi c'est
toujours ce que je réponds je dis donc
si il y en a peut-être fait pas d'eux
mais bon il n'y a pas une piqûre ni un
médicament qui peut faire qu'on ait un
viseur qu'on sache où mettre le coup et
où il n'ya pas de piqûre aux médicaments
paraît qu'ils font qui se découpent le
zune après un bon c'est pas possible
voilà donc où si nous l'avons eu merci
beaucoup